لا شك في ان من بين من يدعون للمقاطعه
اولئك الذين لا يحبون ان يروا بلدا مسلما
ينظم بطوله كاس العالم
لكن هذا لا ينطبق على جميع المحتاجين
[موسيقى]
في عام 2010 عن فوز قطر بتنظيم كاس العالم
انطلقت حمله دعائيه شامله في الاعلام
الغربي باكمله خاصه اعلام اليمين لتشويه
سمعتها
[موسيقى]
لكم قبل اربع سنوات
ولكنها كانت قد ضمت شبه جزيره القرو وكانت
حقوق الانسان
في ذلك الوقت ظهرت انتقادات لكن لم اكن
مخطئه لم يكن هناك حديث عن المقاومه
[موسيقى]
علي القول ان العمال المغتربين فخورون جدا
بتلك الملاعب فهم من بنوها وهؤلاء العمال
المغتربون هم الذين ساعدوا في بناء اقتصاد
قطر
[موسيقى]
تناقض بين وجود قوانين جيتو حيث يطرد
الناس من منازلهم لان بشرتهم لكن
وفي الوقت نفسه تريد مقاطعه قطر على خلفيه
حقوق الانسان
في الدنمارك لان السياسيين لا يرغبون في
مناقشتها لكنهم يريدون مناقشه موضوع قطر
[موسيقى]
الدول الاوروبيه تحس ان هذا انه بطوله كاس
العالم هي حكر لدول اوروبا 11 بطوله من
اصل 22 بطوله طبعا ما ترضى ان دوله في قطر
او دوله عربيه مسلمه تستضيف بطوله مثل كاس
العالم
تقريبا 40 مليون طلب على تذاكر كاس العالم
تنبيع ثلاثه مليون منها اللي هي 3 مليون
اجمالي عدد التذاكر المنتخب كلها